-You guys, today's Friday,
that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some emails
and of course I send out
thank you notes.
And I was just wondering
if you guys...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
some thank you notes
right now.
James, could I have some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Wow.
-James, could you do it in,
like, an organ style?
Can you play like Finn?
-Da-da-da, da-da! Like that.
-[ Vocalizing "Charge" tune ]
Finn. Finn. Finn. Finn. Finn.
Finn. Finn. Finn. Finn.
[ "Charge" tune playing ]
[ Audience clapping on beat ]
I'm not hearing it.
I can't hear it.
[ Tempo increases ]
♪♪
[ Tune crescendos ]
-All: Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that's the jam
right there.
[ Vocalizing "Charge" tune ]
♪ Ba-da boom, bam-boom-bam ♪
[ Funky "Charge" tune playing ]
[ Music ends ]
Oh, yeah.
-Oh. What's that?
[ Audience laughs and applauds ]
-You sat in front of her?
-Yeah, she was right there.
-Wow.
-Those are good seats.
-She was like moving her head
around, trying to see.
-Cause you were wearing your
giant hat that you wear.
-I was wearing my hairpiece.
Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
No, she's very lovely. I do --
I do love running into her.
But it was --
It was a good crowd.
It was super fun.
Yeah, it was great.
But, you know, I --
I just had a better view
than she did.
-Yeah. Whatever.
Yeah, right.
Not a big deal.
-We saw the same thing.
-Yeah, sure.
-Kind of.
-Yeah. But you saw better.
Your your view was about
one foot better, yeah.
-Less.
-Oh, sure.
-Less than one foot.
But just
let's just say better.
-Alright.
Like that. I could --
We could touch hands.
Right? You could reach
or you could reach back
and touch hands.
-Yeah. I had to reach
back and strain myself.
-Right.
[ "Charge" playing
in background ]
-And normally,
if we went together...
-Right, she'd be sitting
next to you.
-Yeah.
And we could hold hands here.
-Right. But no.
-No.
-Back seat.
-Right.
I shouldn't even be
holding her hand at all.
It wasn't a scary play.
It was...
I had no business
holding her hand.
-But you were anyway?
-I think it was her hand.
I didn't look behind me.
-You just put your hand out like
this, and somebody grabbed it?
-Yeah, someone grabbed it.
I was nervous.
-Yeah.
-I was nervous.
I haven't seen a live play
a long time.
-It's been five months.
-I was getting scared.
I go, what's all
these lights and...
-Especially because today --
That was Friday the 13th
eve yesterday.
-Yeah. By the time -- if I --
If the play went long,
I would have been there
on Friday the 13th.
-Scary.
-It ended around 8:39.
-What?
8:39 exactly?
-Yeah.
-Wow. I bet it was a sudden end.
-8:39.
-That's union rules.
-Oh, really?
-Every Broadway show...
Together: has to end at 8:39.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-On Fri-- On Thursday the 12th.
-On Thursday the 12th.
-Yeah, it was good.
You should go see it.
-I will.
[ "Charge" tune crescendos ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Save it, save it.
-[ Laughs ]
Ready.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you, Autumn,
for being fall's legal name.
[ Applause ]
Like a nickname.
-Autumn Joy Smith.
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you, scarves
for being the only clothes
that you put on with attitude.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Really?
Why not?
-[ Chuckles ] Why not?
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
Thank you, step ladders,
You're not my real ladder.
But I can tell you
make my mom very happy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Applause ]
-[ As angry teen ]
Get away from me!
You're not my real ladder!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ As angry teen ]
This is my step ladder, Doug.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-[ Normal voice ] Thank you,
British TV shows
for reminding me that just
because it's in English
doesn't mean
I don't need subtitles.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Indistinct ]
[ Vocalizing
heavy British accent ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
Huh?
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you,
being offered banana bread
for being told all of our
bananas started to rot,
so, well, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
Enjoy that.
-Live it up.
-You don't got to tell me that.
-Yeah.
-Yeah,
they were all going bad.
So we made this for you.
-They were moldy.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you,
VR headsets
for being the coolest way
to look like you're wearing
a jockstrap on your head.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey! Oh!
It smells ripe.
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you,
plastic vampire teeth
for being
Dracula's Invisalign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Couldn't have done that joke
ten years ago.
-Yeah.
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you,
kids who carve pumpkins
with super elaborate designs
for making me think,
"That's really impressive.
As well as.
"Do not anger this kid."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Haha!
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Thank you, the moment
I finally get comfortable in bed
for also being the moment
my bladder goes,
"Guess what?"
There you have it,
everybody.
Those are my
"Thank You Notes."